[Music]
what other talents do you have that we
don't know about
I can regular juggle regular job no I
mean like juggle you can juggle
I can juggle yeah you can't ruggle why'd
you say regular is there another kind I
consider what I did on your show head
juggling okay soccer yeah you too come
on yeah yeah okay head juggling but you
can you can juggle funny you mention it
yeah I keep these fruits and balls in
his bowl at all times here just in case
somebody mentions they can juggle I also
have a McLobster handy if that should
come up a second time would you care to
demonstrate this juggling present
[Applause]
Oh your godsister take what should I
jungle with those potatoes are my lunch
be this your toaster for me
Patos balls are oranges that's the
crowds pick it's an interactive game
[Applause]
hold it hold it the voting is over now
you just you just played a game of let's
ask the angry mob boss potato from the
castle I grew up on film sets and you
have a lot of free time basically okay
so this is just like like a lonely
sadness trap Thank You Ellen for
demonstrating your lonely sadness
instead of friends
should I do it yeah I need to stand is
that okay yeah your ever you want and
we're into it yeah the crowds happier
that you've just chosen their favorite
I'm in front of people and there's
cameras so I'm a little scared I've
never noticed
[Applause]
[Applause]
really chief now that was very good
you've now set the precedent that any
time you come here to talk about a movie
I'm gonna I'll jump through fire yeah
yes I am a plate spinner I conveniently
have what's up let the movie the East I
saw this film it's a fascinating story
it's a great idea for a film and and
obviously it's getting great reviews
people love this movie and it's about a
group of I would say a fringe group of
activists that are very passionate about
going after corporations corporations
they consider to be evil and this and
someone's trying to infiltrate the group
and really terrific idea and it centers
around this thing that I hadn't really
known about called the freegan lifestyle
and this is a real thing could you can
you explain what freegan is to people
yeah absolutely it's essentially people
who want to live on the outskirts of
capitalism and don't want to take you
know accountability for their own
footprint on the world so it's
essentially about seeing the value and
waste and using that so for example
dumpster diving and getting food that
otherwise would go to a dump good food
and taking it and cooking it and eating
it that would be an example of it right
so these are people that actually they
don't want to they consider it almost
like a mortal sin to go and buy
something from a store they want to go
into a dumpster get food that's been
thrown away and eat it yeah and I
understand why that would sound like
really grotesque to people and but you
know a lot of behind nice grocery stores
it's they legally have to throw food
that has a sell-by date and it's good
packaged food that otherwise would go to
the dump and a lot of these people who
recover this food cook it and serve it
to people in their community who
otherwise would go hungry and you
there's something called permaculture
you got a little bit into this yourself
you tried it out for a while which is
really just trying to dispose of what
everything in your life yourself in a
natural way
yeah permaculture is essentially making
our lifestyles act in a cyclical way
that sort of mirrors the way nature does
it so I went and studied permaculture
design and eco village development and a
place called Lost Valley in Oregon and
you know met freegans they're young
people who live that lifestyle and so it
helped with making this movie
you know it sort of been in a sort of
similar environment intentional living
community it's this this movie it's
actually got a lot of great thriller
qualities to it and then you learn about
this other lifestyle which is really
neat it's very well portrayed